[Music]
I think it's I'm a believer in the
precautionary principle as I've just
said and I think we have to worry about
possible consequences of things that we
do and the ability to edit our own
genomes is one thing we ought to worry
about I'm not sure it's so much an
ethical problem as a more practical
problem what were the consequences be
would the consequences be bad and they
might be I think it's worth noticing
that long before CRISPR long before
became capable of editing our genomes in
any way we have been editing the genomes
of domestic animals and plants by
artificial selection not artificial
mutation which is what we're now talking
about but artificial selection when you
think that a Pekinese is a wolf a
modified or four genetically modified
wolf get modified not by directly
manipulating genes but by choosing for
breeding individuals who have certain
characteristics for example small
snub-nosed etc and making a wolf turn
into a Pekinese well we've been doing
that very successfully with domestic
animals like dogs cows domestic plants
like maize for a long time we've never
done that to humans or hardly at all
Hitler tried it but it's never really
been properly done with us as humans I'm
glad to say so if they've never done
that with humans with the easy way which
is artificial selection
it's not obvious why we would suddenly
start doing it the difficult way which
is by genetic direction etic
manipulation so it doesn't seem to be
any great eagerness to do it over the
last few centuries anyway a lot of
people have problems of what they call
designer babies you could imagine a
future scenario in which people go to a
doctor and say doctor we want our baby
to be a musical genius please edit the
Jesus so that we have the same genes as
the Box family had or something like
that to make them into musical genius I
mean that horrifies many people
not totally obvious why there's any more
horrifying than parents who are
ambitious for the musical fief of their
child forcing the child to practice the
piano the other day it there are
differences of course this the forcing
it to practice is may be unpleasant for
the child who doesn't go on to the next
generation
changing the genes does so there is a
difference there but at least people who
shudder with horror at a designer baby
who's a musical genius people who
shudder with horror at that why don't
you shut up with horror at forcing a
child to have music lessons when it
doesn't want to or practice music when
it doesn't want to I think although
there is an analogy between
technological evolution and biological
evolution it's dangerous to push that
analogy too far I've just been decrying
the view that everybody is an expert I'm
not an expert on technology and I think
that every scientist needs to admit when
they don't know yet the analogy is there
things change gradually is that the
evolution of the aeroplane starting from
the Wright brothers beginning of the
20th century until the present it's been
spectacularly fast but it is it is
gradual evolution and it looks to some
extent like biological evolution but
whether it occurs by natural selection
that's open to argument you could say it
does occur by a form of natural
selection but it's not the same kind of
natural selection so I don't regard
myself as a biological evolutionist as
qualified to talk about technological
evolution I'm interested in the analogy
but I think it only is an analogy and it
doesn't go too far
[Music]